sa chemise ananas porte-bonheur n'a pas
empêché icarunakamura le roi du speechez
de se faire détrôner par Magnus Carsen
au terme d'une finale à couper le
souffle malgré un terrible trop d'air de
trois défaites d'affilée le numéro 1
mondial est mis fin aux règles de
l'Américain qui deraient depuis 5 ans
dominer en début de match Naka d'abord
profiter d'une faute de souris adverse
pour débloquer son compteur puis à
renversé la vapeur grâce à un incroyable
sacrifice de dames salué par son rival
le vent en poupe il a creusé les carpes
avant de subir le réveil de 45 qui a
permis au champion du monde de blitz de
revenir à hauteur avant les bullets
venez d'un petit point avant l'ultime
bataille n'a qu'avait légalisation au
bout des doigts quand il s'est précipité
ratant le mat et laissant un sauvetage
miraculeux au norvégien qui a pas caché
sa joie au moment de conclure